hey everyone it's Jonah here so the
month of ramadhan is approaching and
this is the perfect time to make
significant changes to your lifestyle
I'm not a Muslim but as a Malaysian
Ramadan is widely practiced over here so
to help you through a fit and healthy
Ramadan
I've put together a 28-day workout and
also meal plan just for you so direct
links to both of the plans are in my
description box below I have a balanced
meal plan and also a vegan meal plan so
click on the link below and be sure to
print them out so fasting during the
month of Ramadan is a perfect time to
make significant changes to your
lifestyle such as understanding food
portion learning self-control
understanding your relationship with
food and also really appreciate the food
years in blessed with don't wait until
the first day of Ramadan to start eating
better or start working out you have to
make changes right now okay because
let's face it that will not happen if
you leave it to tomorrow so start
eliminating sugary salty and static food
and drinks from your diet reduce on a
cabin intake and learn to drink more
water right now this is also the perfect
time for you to start adjusting your
workout schedule to how you plan to work
out during the month of Ramadan so I've
created two videos which you can click
and what you're right here in the
Ramadan healthy meal guide I spoke about
the type of food you should be eating
for Easter and Suho portion size and
also through to avoid as for the how to
workout during Ramadan I look about as a
worker intensity work a duration when
it's the best time to workout and also
the types of workout you should be doing
so be sure to click and watch both
videos right here because I trust that
you will find the tips and methods to be
really useful if you find ahead and if
you're prepared both mentally and
physically chances are you are more
likely to succeed and stay disciplined
throughout the entire month select this
month of Ramadan we've started to a new
you by practicing healthy eating habits
and also let us be more conscious about
our well-being follow the meal plan and
workout plan and share your progress
with me through all the 28 days so I
want to see your pictures on Instagram
and Facebook tag me as a join us on
official and hashtag fitter
fasting ok so share this video
with a friends and also subscribe to my
youtube channel turn on the notification
button so that you will know every time
I upload a new video happy Ramadan guys
and all the best